some women firefighters telling me that  they were afraid to go on operational  matters because they didn't have any  respect for the the men around them  because of the the way they were being  treated the black firefighter who found  a noose by his locker another Muslim  firefighter who found that found out he  didn't know at the time that bacon had  been  um scraped on his dinner plate before he  ate on several occasions  um it was uh there were so many of these  events I mean I'd be frank I mean I've  dealt with as probably think of the  worst that human beings can do to each  other but some of these stories I heard  were heartbreaking uh you know people  were talking about their experiences in  a way that was really real to them and  they'd never be able to talk about  before